Jake:就是你如果腰斩的话不就不能拨了吗
Jake: If you get cut in half, it can't be broadcast, right?
Lucia: 你好认真的在思索这个可能性
Lucia: You seriously considered this possibility.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:你真的不把我的命当命
Alice: You really don't value my life.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 太不重视员工的身心健康
Lucia: You really don't care about the employees' wellbeing.
Lucia: 老板这是洗洁精吗
Lucia: Boss, is this dish soap?
Jake:嗯那还是暂时暂时
Jake: Yeah, but just for now.
Alice:嗯嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Jake:我们不要腰斩啊
Jake: Let's not cut it off.
Jake:这个哈哈哈
Jake: This, hahaha
Lucia: 暂时哈哈
Lucia: Just for now, haha
Alice:嗯暂时
Alice: Yeah, for now.
Lucia: 保留到
Lucia: Keep it until
Lucia: 保留到录制完作为于心节目是吗
Lucia: Keep it until the recording is over, right?
Alice:小哥哥你
Alice: Hey, you
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈对不起我笑点低哈哈
Lucia: Haha, sorry, I laugh easily, haha
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey
Jake:哎喂
Jake: Hey, hello
Jake:哎我我那个要扫房间
Jake: Hey, I, I need to sweep the room
Jake:然后你你你这个屋子我就这么扫了
Jake: Then I'll just sweep this room like this
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Jake:哈哈行行挺有艺术感
Jake: Haha, alright, it looks artistic
Lucia: 他还在说修硕吗
Lucia: Is he still talking about Shure?
Jake:我觉得挺好
Jake: I think it's good
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah
Jake:好嗯拜拜
Jake: Okay, bye
Lucia: 我说他还在说修硕吗
Lucia: I said, is he still talking about Shure?
Alice:哪吒啊
Alice: Nezha?
Lucia: 宝你的衣服洗了吗
Lucia: Honey, did you wash your clothes?
Alice:谁啊这么快对
Alice: Whoa, that was fast
Lucia: 啊这么快
Lucia: Ah, so fast
Lucia: 好的吧
Lucia: Alright then
Alice:我本来想吃完饭再洗的
Alice: I originally wanted to wash them after dinner
Alice:他一直在这催我说我懒
Alice: He kept pushing me, saying I was lazy
其他人：那是自然
Others: Naturally
Jake:就已经洗完了嗯
Jake: They're already washed, yeah
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah
Lucia: 我在给上面抹洗洁精
Lucia: I'm scrubbing the top with detergent
Alice:真是醉了
Alice: Seriously, I'm so tired
Alice:你把这个粉撒到这里面
Alice: Sprinkle this powder in here
Lucia: 要不我还是用洗衣机洗一遍算了
Lucia: Maybe I should just use the washing machine
Lucia: 因为刚那个掉下来的他
Lucia: Because the thing that fell earlier
Jake:可以对
Jake: Sure, go ahead
Jake:啊 15分钟不算十
Jake: Ah, 15 minutes isn't long
Jake:十十五分钟算什么
Jake: What is 15 minutes?
Alice:磕一下磕哒磕哒
Alice: Just knock it, knock it
Alice:好
Alice: Okay
Lucia: 还可以选择30分钟模式
Lucia: You can also choose the 30-minute mode.
Alice:OK
Alice: OK
Lucia: 相当于你在之前的时间损耗上
Lucia: It means your previous time loss...
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 增加了100%的成本
Lucia: Increased the cost by 100%.
Jake:呵呵好的
Jake: Hehe, got it.
Lucia: 重点不在于绝对值
Lucia: The key is not the absolute value.
Lucia: 而在于它的百分比
Lucia: But the percentage.
Jake:嗯好的
Jake: Hmm, okay.
Alice:看完两个
Alice: After watching two...
Lucia: 投资学告诉我们
Lucia: Investment studies tell us...
Jake:好的
Jake: Got it.
Jake:这个能带来什么收益
Jake: What kind of returns can this bring?
Lucia: 睡衣睡衣
Lucia: Pajamas, pajamas.
Lucia: 就是你的裤子会变干净
Lucia: Your pants will be cleaner.
Lucia: 也许吧当然还有一些风险
Lucia: Maybe, but of course, there are some risks.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 就是没洗干净
Lucia: Like not being washed properly.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 我们要尽量保持这个风险可控
Lucia: We need to keep this risk manageable.
Lucia: 也就是说
Lucia: That means...
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 尽量不要把饭渣掉在自己身上
Lucia: Try not to drop food on yourself.
Alice:老板
Alice: Boss.
Alice:这几天为数不多的桌子干净的环节
Alice: The few clean table moments these days...
Alice:是不是都是我创造的
Alice: Aren't they all created by me?
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Alice:卧槽吓死我了
Alice: Damn, that scared me.
Jake:这是
Jake: This is...
Jake:这这没没说错啊
Jake: That's not wrong.
Lucia: 是哪一个
Lucia: Which one?
Jake:为什么掉下来了
Jake: Why did it fall?
Alice:这个地是不是可以叫那个清洁的那个
Alice: Should we call the cleaning service for this floor?
Jake:对我在叫他们
Jake: Yes, I'm calling them.
Alice:OK
Alice: OK.
Jake:不但是这个地我们其实
Jake: But it's not just this floor, we actually...
Jake:呃他今天明天都可以搞
Jake: They can do it today or tomorrow.
Alice:哦那明天也行
Alice: Oh, tomorrow works too.
Jake:或者我们走了都可以搞
Jake: Or they can do it after we leave.
Alice:只要反正
Alice: Anyway, as long as...
Jake:这个地不重要
Jake: This place isn't important.
Alice:只要你看着不难受无所谓
Alice: As long as it doesn't bother you, it's fine.
Jake:嗯确实不怎么好受
Jake: Yeah, it doesn't feel that great.
Jake:但是
Jake: But...
Alice:但是可以装作看不见
Alice: But you can pretend not to see it.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Alice:你可以不出来
Alice: You don't have to come out.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:呵呵呵确实
Jake: Hehehe, true.
Lucia: you should not pass
Lucia: You shall not pass.
Alice:我妈就有点洁癖
Alice: My mom is a bit of a clean freak.
Alice:就是地上就拖的拖
Alice: When she mops the floor...
Alice:拖完地之后地上有水痕反光
Alice: After she mops, there are water marks that reflect light.
Alice:被他看见他都很难受
Alice: It bothers her a lot when she sees it.
Alice:然后他就老嫌我
Alice: Then she always complains about me.
Alice:干就是干家务啥的就不细致
Alice: She says I don't do housework meticulously.
Alice:说我邋遢
Alice: She calls me messy.
其他人：感觉说的是实话
Others: Sounds like the truth.
Alice:确实是实话
Alice: It is true.
Alice:我确实很邋遢
Alice: I am really messy.
Alice:然后但是我就让他你就不能不看吗
Alice: But I just tell her, can't you just not look at it?
Alice:呵呵
Alice: Hehe.
Lucia: 我怎么觉得我上次搓的也是这条裤子
Lucia: Why do I feel like I washed these pants last time too?
Lucia: 我的AI收集到最重要的数据就是
Lucia: My AI collected the most important data.
Lucia: 我经常来搓这条裤子
Lucia: I often come to wash these pants.
Lucia: 他肯定会以为
Lucia: He must think...
Lucia: 这条裤子对我来说有什么特别
Lucia: These pants are special to me in some way.
Lucia: 特别怎么说呢
Lucia: Special, how to say...
Lucia: 独特的意义
Lucia: Unique meaning.
Lucia: 我才会这么专心致志的洗他
Lucia: That's why I'm so focused on washing them.
Jake:他是看到这个裤子就要搓一会
Jake: Every time he sees these pants, he has to wash them for a bit.
Lucia: 看到这个就
Lucia: When he sees them...
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahahahahahahahahaha
Alice:看见这个裤子就要搓一搓
Alice: When he sees these pants, he has to wash them.
Lucia: 不是最后他会建起这样一个链接吗
Lucia: Eventually, he'll make that connection, right?
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 怪不得
Lucia: No wonder.
Lucia: 怪不得游戏里有那么多人工智障模型
Lucia: No wonder there are so many dumb AI models in the game.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 我我我玩使命召唤五五的时候因为哎
Lucia: When I played Call of Duty 5, because, um...
Jake:嗯嗯哎
Jake: Mm-hmm, yeah.
Lucia: 你在哪里
Lucia: Where are you?
Lucia: 你在哈哈哈
Lucia: You're here, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈环绕似的
Jake: Haha, it's like surround sound.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:3D的 5D的
Alice: 3D, 5D.
Lucia: 我玩视频召唤5的时候
Lucia: When I played Call of Duty 5...
Lucia: 因为他那个比较老嘛
Lucia: Because it's an older game.
Lucia: 他好多年前的游戏
Lucia: It's been around for many years.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Lucia: 所以就有时候穿模糊穿的很奇怪
Lucia: So sometimes the textures get really weird.
Lucia: 就比如说我把敌人炸死之后
Lucia: For example, after I blow up an enemy...
Lucia: 然后这个可以
Lucia: Then it can...
Lucia: 这个会啊
Lucia: It can...
Jake:没关系没关系啊
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Lucia: OK就我把敌人炸死之后
Lucia: Okay, so after I blow up an enemy...
Lucia: 没事反正是虚拟人物
Lucia: It's fine, they're just virtual characters.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Lucia: 然后就是就是
Lucia: So, then...
Lucia: 那个靴子就会浮起来在半空中停留
Lucia: The boots would just float in mid-air.
Lucia: 他没有落到地上
Lucia: They wouldn't fall to the ground.
Jake:OK
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 就就那样卡在那里
Lucia: They just stay stuck there.
Jake:OK
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 然后我当时卧倒
Lucia: Then I went prone.
Lucia: 因为我害怕
Lucia: Because I was scared.
Lucia: 就是对方射击我
Lucia: That the other side would shoot me.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Lucia: 我卧倒之后
Lucia: After I went prone...
Lucia: 我就看到刚被我打死的敌人的靴子
Lucia: I saw the boots of the enemy I just killed...
Lucia: 飘在我的面前
Lucia: Floating in front of me.
Jake:哈哈哈哈悬浮一个靴子
Jake: Hahaha, a floating boot.
Lucia: 好恐怖啊
Lucia: It was so creepy.
Alice:小姐姐我要洗个手
Alice: Sis, I need to wash my hands.
Lucia: 对真的是悬浮一个靴子
Lucia: Yeah, a floating boot, really.
Alice:哇哦you so勤奋
Alice: Wow, you’re so diligent.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Alice:OK拿个纸你
Alice: OK, grab a piece of paper.
Alice:你是把我的歌停了吗
Alice: Did you stop my song?
Jake:把我的歌停了吗
Jake: Did you stop my song?
其他人：没有露西停的
Others: No, Lucia stopped it.
Alice:我靠神经病啊
Alice: Oh my god, are you crazy?
其他人：接受不了网络暴力
Others: Can't handle cyberbullying.
Alice:重新给你放吧
Alice: Let me play it for you again.
Alice:一到那就是卡壳
Alice: It always gets stuck there.
Alice:OK了
Alice:搁这吧
Alice:稍微扫一下吧
Alice: Sweep a bit.
Alice:看着好难受
Alice: It looks so messy.
Lucia: 来扫吧我裤子脱好了
Lucia: Come on, sweep, I've already taken off my pants.
Alice:OK
Alice: OK.
Alice:这地上粘的像泥一样
Alice: The floor is sticky like mud.
Lucia: 谁的轮廓
Lucia: Whose outline is this?
Jake:哎等会等会
Jake: Hey, wait a minute, wait a minute.
Jake:我这一圈相机没开所以
Jake: My cameras weren't on, so...
Jake:所以
Jake: So...
Jake:一会你先把这个扫把到门口等着
Jake: Sweep to the door first and wait.
Jake:然后我开
Jake: Then I'll turn them on.
Jake:我开一完之后就开始扫
Jake: Once I turn them on, you can start sweeping.
Jake:好对
Jake: Alright, good.
Alice:没开吗
Jake:扫下有叫什么
Jake: Sweep, what's it called?
Jake:扫把扫帚下牛垃圾
Jake: Sweep the trash with the broom.
Jake:哈哈听
Jake: Haha, listen.
Lucia: 我要把扫把放到哪
Lucia: Where should I put the broom?
Lucia: 你刚说随便一个地方
Lucia: You just said anywhere.
Jake:就是进场的
Jake: Just in the entrance.
Jake:进场就行了
Jake: The entrance is fine.
Alice:虽然这个没有录
Alice: Although this wasn't recorded.
Lucia: 可
Lucia: Okay.
Alice:但是这个不是录上了嗯
Alice: But this part was recorded, right.
Jake:这个这个没问题
Jake: This, this is fine.
Jake:对就开一下子
Jake: Yeah, just turn it on.
Alice:好的那我可以嗑瓜子了吗
Alice: Okay, can I eat sunflower seeds now?
Jake:可以哈哈哈
Jake: Sure, hahaha.
Alice:可以的哈哈哈
Alice: Yes, you can, hahaha.
Lucia: 可以往地下扔
Lucia: Can I throw them on the floor?
Jake:嗑瓜子哈哈哈挺好挺好
Jake: Eating sunflower seeds, haha, pretty good, pretty good.
Lucia: 哈哈哈给他多制造一下
Lucia: Haha, let's give him more to do.
Alice:我我不咋地上
Alice: I, I'm not really good at it.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:等会等会你你一会再水滴润
Jake: Wait, wait, you can do it in a bit.
Jake:就是一会我们造成一个一一会
Jake: We'll just create a, a moment later.
Alice:我我不扔地上
Alice: I, I won't throw it on the ground.
Lucia: 没事反正会扫掉的
Lucia: It's okay, it'll get swept up anyway.
Jake:就是你一边嗑瓜子然后一边往地上
Jake: Just eat sunflower seeds and drop them on the ground.
Jake:然后就在旁边扫
Jake: And then sweep it up nearby.
Alice:真的吗
Alice: Really?
Alice:这样会不会给我打上一个人品
Alice: Won't this make me look bad?
Lucia: 好奇怪的场景啊
Lucia: What a weird scene.
Alice:人品低劣的标签
Alice: Like a person with low character.
Lucia: 那你先嗑一会
Lucia: Then you eat for a while first.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我再进来扫
Lucia: I'll come in and sweep later.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈要不然有一种
Lucia: Hahaha, otherwise it feels like...
Lucia: 就这两个动作同时发声就很奇怪
Lucia: If both actions happen at the same time, it's really weird.
Lucia: 但如果发声完再发声就同时发声
Lucia: But if it happens one after another, it's still weird.
Jake:那就等会
Jake: Then just wait a bit.
Alice:同时发生
Alice: At the same time.
Alice:好像是我这人故意找点事什么的
Alice: It seems like I'm intentionally causing trouble.
Lucia: 那我跟你一起嗑吧要不
Lucia: How about I eat with you instead?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:要不来吧
Alice: Or let's do it.
Jake:等会再嗑喝等会再磕等会再喝
Jake: Eat later, drink later, eat later, drink later.
Jake:忍忍一下忍一下忍
Jake: Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Jake:一下
Jake: Hold on.
Alice:我就不能一直嗑吗
Alice: Can't I just keep eating?
Jake:你可以啊你可以一直嗑
Jake: Sure, you can keep eating.
Alice:来吧大爷
Alice: Go ahead, boss.
Jake:来了我怕你嗑饱了嘛
Jake: I'm just worried you'll get full.
Alice:无所谓
Alice: Doesn't matter.
Lucia: 还有健胃消食片呢
Lucia: There's digestive tablets anyway.
Jake:哈哈哈那你先吃
Jake: Hahaha, then you eat first.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 人均造梗大师
Lucia: Everyone's a master of creating memes.
Lucia: （歌词）执子手吹散苍茫茫烟波
Lucia: (Lyrics) Holding your hand, we scatter the vast misty waves
Alice:小姐姐太勤奋了爱上了
Alice: This young lady is so diligent, I'm in love.
Lucia: 这算不算一种义工呢
Lucia: Does this count as volunteering?
Alice:加工资吧老板
Alice: Give us a raise, boss.
Jake:晚上吃点好的
Jake: Let's have a nice dinner tonight.
Jake:怎么样
Jake: How about that?
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Sure.
Jake:就到门口那个彩票店旁边
Jake: Just next to the lottery shop at the corner.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Alice:彩票店旁边
Alice: Next to the lottery shop.
Alice:吃狗唉不对
Alice: Eating dogs, wait no...
Jake:哎不对这是什么东西
Jake: Wait, no, what is that?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈是什么东西
Jake: Hahaha, what even is that?
Alice:对不起哈哈哈这个这个哈哈哈哈
Alice: Sorry, hahaha, this, this, hahaha.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Jake:哈哈吃什么
Jake: Haha, what are we eating?
Alice:呃吃狗店的
Alice: Uh, from the dog shop.
Alice:小食
Alice: Snacks.
Lucia: 狗食哈
Lucia: Dog food, ha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha.
Lucia: 我在家看家
Lucia: I'll stay home and watch the house.
Alice:看门有我们的CP狗就可以了
Alice: Guarding the house, our CP dog can do that.
Alice:你要跟我们一起
Alice: You should come with us.
Lucia: 我给CP狗喂点吃
Lucia: I'll feed the CP dog.
Jake:昨天那俩不是卖了吗
Jake: Didn't we sell those two yesterday?
Lucia: 的
Lucia: Yes.
Jake:没带走是吧
Jake: They didn't take them, right?
Lucia: 没有啊
Lucia: No, they didn't.
Alice:没
Alice: Nope.
Jake:没有好嘞
Jake: No? Alright then.
Jake:净赚这黑店
Jake: This is just pure profit for this shady shop.
Jake:纯黑店这是
Jake: Purely a shady shop.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈近赚纯黑店
Jake: Hahaha, pure profit from this shady shop.
Lucia: 不是咱们的那个coin呢
Lucia: What about our coin?
Lucia: 上链那个coin不是说要
Lucia: The blockchain coin, weren't we supposed to...
Jake:但是他们不是购买了吗对吧
Jake: But didn't they buy it, right?
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Jake:购买了商品应该带走
Jake: If you buy something, you should take it with you.
Lucia: 之前不是说那个coin要就是
Lucia: Didn't we say before that the coin needs to be...
Jake:对统计一下
Jake: Yes, to keep track.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Jake:但是统计的那个人发烧了
Jake: But the person keeping track has a fever.
Lucia: 好吧
Lucia: Okay then.
Lucia: 那我创建一个钱包吧
Lucia: Then I'll create a wallet.
Jake:哎可以等他
Jake: Hey, you can wait for him.
Lucia: 不是我前两年
Lucia: No, a couple of years ago...
Lucia: 我前两年
Lucia: A couple of years ago...
Lucia: 前两年
Lucia: 那个就是NFT在国内刚很火的时候
Lucia: When NFTs were just becoming popular in China...
Alice:搁这
Alice: Put it here.
Lucia: 我之前是想
Lucia: I was thinking...
Alice:这是
Alice: This is...
其他人：那什么我问你
Others: Hey, let me ask you something.
Alice:纸
Alice: Paper.
Alice:黑色的纸
Alice: Black paper.
Lucia: what
Lucia: What?
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Lucia: 我那会是想创一个钱包了
Lucia: Back then, I wanted to create a wallet.
Lucia: 然后本来还有几个东西
Lucia: And there were a few things...
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 我想试着上一下练
Lucia: I wanted to try to get on the chain.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 但是最后让我放弃的原因是什么呢
Lucia: But the reason I gave up in the end was...
Lucia: gasp太贵了
Lucia: Gas fees were too expensive.
Jake:哦好吧对消耗太大对
Jake: Oh, right, the consumption is too high.
Lucia: 对然后我就没搞
Lucia: Yeah, so I didn't do it.
Lucia: 但既然你们已经商量过了
Lucia: But since you guys have already discussed it...
Lucia: 那我就只需要创一个钱包就行了
Lucia: Then I just need to create a wallet.
Lucia: 创钱包又不要钱
Lucia: Creating a wallet doesn't cost anything.
Jake:对是的
Jake: Yes, that's right.
Lucia: 让我倒过来薅老板羊毛
Lucia: Let me reverse and fleece the boss.
Jake:十年之后
Jake: Ten years later...
Lucia: 对谁知道呢
Lucia: Yeah, who knows?
Jake:买十十年之后把这套房子买下来
Jake: Buy this house ten years later.
Lucia: 万一10年之后
Lucia: What if ten years later...
Lucia: 你成了下一个艾隆马斯克
Lucia: You become the next Elon Musk.
Jake:哈OK
Jake: Ha OK
Lucia: 那咱这个Coin不就值钱了吗是吧
Lucia: Then our Coin will be valuable, right?
Jake:那确实
Jake: Indeed
Lucia: 那我这个
Lucia: Then I
Lucia: 不能错过这个初始股东的机会
Lucia: Can't miss this initial shareholder opportunity
Lucia: 领导苟富贵勿相忘
Lucia: Boss, don't forget us when you're rich
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Jake:哈哈哈必不会
Jake: Hahaha, I won't forget you
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha
Jake:相忘的至少
Jake: At least not forget you
Alice:这是个甲壳虫
Alice: This is a beetle
Alice:你知道吗
Alice: You know?
Alice:这是他的尸体
Alice: This is its corpse
其他人：谁把他杀死的
Others: Who killed it?
Alice:刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting
Lucia: 开了吗
Lucia: Is it on?
Jake:快了
Jake: Almost
Lucia: 快我迫不及待的想扫地哈哈哈
Lucia: Hurry, I can't wait to sweep the floor hahaha
Alice:快了
Alice: Almost
Jake:还差一个
Jake: Just one more thing
Jake:哎我去
Jake: Oh my
Alice:你要听别的歌吗
Alice: Do you want to listen to another song?
其他人：行啊
Others: Sure
Alice:说吧
Alice: Go ahead
其他人：你随便放吧
Others: You can play anything
Alice:你给我指定呗
Alice: You pick for me
Alice:林俊杰
Alice: JJ Lin
其他人：不要听腻了
Others: No, we're tired of him
Alice:那你说名
Alice: Then you name one
Lucia: 这个衬衣看起来真的特别舒服
Lucia: This shirt looks really comfortable
Lucia: 嗯棉麻的
Lucia: Hmm, it's cotton and linen
Alice:嗯棉麻的
Alice: Hmm, it's cotton and linen
Alice:我平时听的
Alice: The ones I usually listen to
Alice:你要让我
Alice: You want me
Alice:挑歌我得挑半个小时了
Alice:这人比较墨迹
Alice: This guy is a bit slow
Alice:好说爱你好吗
Alice: How about Love You?
其他人：好行
Others: Sure, okay
Alice:就放这这就是这里的嗯
Alice: Just play this, this is it, yeah
Alice:嗯呐
Alice: Mm-hmm
Alice:就是放那的无妨
Alice: It's fine to just leave it there.
Alice:一开始
Alice: At the beginning
其他人：别丢脸哈哈
Others: Don't embarrass yourself, haha
Alice:哈不是
Alice: Haha, no
其他人：直接进副歌哈哈
Others: Jump straight into the chorus, haha
Alice:这次绝对进对了
Alice: This time we'll definitely get it right.
Alice:一开始哈哈哈
Alice: From the beginning, hahaha
其他人：咦哈哈哈
Others: Eh, hahaha
Alice:怎么了
Alice: What happened?
Jake:还有
Jake: There's more.
Alice:咋了
Alice: What?
Alice:什么受伤了
Alice: Who got hurt?
Jake:哎哎
Jake: Hey hey
Alice:不用了
Alice: No need.
Jake:即将开始
Jake: About to start.
Alice:关爱情
Alice: About love.
Jake:哼哼哼哼挺好
Jake: Humming, pretty good.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Alice:干嘛
Alice: What are you doing?
Jake:好各位各就各位开始磕
Jake: Alright everyone, get into position and start chewing.
Jake:哎稍等
Jake: Hey, hold on.
Jake:对有一个他有问题
Jake: Yeah, there's a problem with one.
Jake:就是这个
Jake: This one.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Lucia: 好失望哦哈
Lucia: So disappointing, haha
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Alice:好了
Alice: Alright.
Lucia: 啊哎你可以实时看到回放吗
Lucia: Can you see the playback in real-time?
Alice:恶心
Alice:你还你戴上干嘛
Alice: Why are you putting it on?
其他人：我刚戴上
Others: I just put it on.
Alice:哎呦卧槽
Alice: Whoa, damn.
Alice:真扔出去了
Alice: Really threw it out.
Lucia: 因为刚好在那个啥有音乐哈哈
Lucia: Because there was music at that moment, haha
Lucia: 棒棒的
Lucia: Awesome.
Jake:开磕开扫
Jake: Start chewing, start cleaning.
Alice:这样显得我特别没素质说实话
Alice: This makes me look so uncultured, to be honest.
Lucia: 没事我一会跟你一块嗑
Lucia: It's okay, I'll chew with you later.
Alice:给我打上一个人品低劣的标签
Alice: Label me as a person of low character.
Lucia: 不会的那要不我们想想换个活动
Lucia: If not, should we think about changing the activity?
Alice:无所谓啊
Alice: Doesn't matter.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice:又没认识我
Alice: They don't even know me.
Alice:这样是不是显得很无理
Alice: Does this seem rude?
Lucia: 没有啊我觉得这样就是这很
Lucia: No, I think it's just fine.
Lucia: 正常吧
Lucia: It's normal, right?
Lucia: 应该就就是我如果周围没有垃圾桶
Lucia: If there's no trash can around me,
Lucia: 我就会扔到
Lucia: I would just throw it...
Alice:嗯但其实这有垃圾桶
Alice: Yeah, but there is a trash can here.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia: 哦没事
Lucia: Oh, it's fine.
Lucia: 我们可以假装他没有
Lucia: We can pretend it isn't there.
Lucia: 我们假设我们假设他没有
Lucia: Let's assume, let's assume it's not there.
Alice:你嗑瓜子吗
Alice: Do you eat sunflower seeds?
其他人：我不嗑
Others: I don't.
Alice:为什么
其他人：做文明有理一勾人
Others: Acting polite and civilized...
Alice:你给这一勾上了
Alice: You got roped into this.
Alice:什么意思啊
Alice: What do you mean?
Alice:我嗑瓜子我就不文明了
Alice: Eating sunflower seeds makes me uncivilized?
其他人：不是这个意思哈
Others: That's not what we meant.
Alice:你不就这意思吗
Alice: That's exactly what you meant.
其他人：没有
Others: No.
Alice:一开始一二
Alice: At first, one, two...
Alice:那不能喝
Alice: Can't drink that.
Alice:那喝给你毒死
Alice: It'll poison you.
Alice:给咱婷寻摸个什么
Alice: Let's look for something for Ting.
Alice:嗯啥玩意这是
Alice: Hmm, what is this?
Alice:冰块
Alice: Ice cubes.
Jake:来来嗑瓜子
Jake: Come on, let's eat sunflower seeds.
Alice:我俩是你的后勤保卫军
Alice: We're your logistics support team.
Lucia: 哦那个是那个是修硕的
Lucia: Oh, that belongs to Shure.
Lucia: 嘿呀哎
Lucia: Hey, hey.
Lucia: 叮咚
Lucia: Ding dong.
Lucia: 这应该可以先倒一下
Lucia: This should be poured first.
Lucia: 哎呀
Lucia: Ah!
Lucia: 我在想我要不要把一些东西寄回去
Lucia: I'm thinking about whether to send some stuff back.
Lucia: 感觉
Lucia: Feels like...
Lucia: 我们要收集一下寄快递的那个啥吗
Lucia: Do we need to gather things to ship?
Jake:可以啊就是顺丰上门呗
Jake: Sure, we can just use SF Express for home pickup.
Lucia: 附近有没有快递点
Lucia: Is there a nearby courier point?
Lucia: 顺丰太贵了
Lucia: SF Express is too expensive.
Tasha: 他会上门吗
Tasha: Will they come to pick it up?
Shure: 250米
Shure: 250 meters away.
Jake:那还有什么上门
Jake: What other services offer home pickup?
Jake:别的应该也有上门
Jake: Other services should have home pickup too.
Lucia: 我们可以去快递点寄
Lucia: We can go to the courier point to send it.
Alice:那也可以
Alice: That works too.
Tasha: 不行为啥
Tasha: Why not?
Tasha: 东西太多了
Tasha: We have too many things.
Jake:哦对拿回来要三个人
Jake: Oh right, we need three people to carry everything back.
Jake:今天可厉害了
Jake: Today was pretty intense.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Huh?
Jake: 昨天昨天早上三个人满满的
Jake: Yesterday morning, three people were fully loaded.
Jake:一只手都空空的
Jake: And one hand was still empty.
Lucia: 哦你说取快递
Lucia: Oh, you mean picking up the packages?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 对我感觉我我我那些东西
Lucia: Yeah, I feel like my stuff...
Lucia: 其实大部分的东西还是能放得下
Lucia: Actually, most of the stuff can fit.
Lucia: 但有有一些东西有点
Lucia: But some things are a bit...
Alice:底下底下啊
Alice: Downstairs, downstairs.
Alice:那不是吗
Alice: Isn't that right?
其他人：我那瓶没喝完哦
Others: I haven't finished my bottle.
Alice:地可以
Alice: The floor is fine.
Alice:先不拖吧
Alice: Let's not mop it now.
Alice:等着明天阿姨来拖
Alice: We'll wait for the cleaning lady tomorrow.
Alice:累死了
Alice: I'm exhausted.
Alice:装作看不见
Alice:我那个地毯我想寄回去
Alice: I want to send my carpet back.
Lucia: 你是寄到学校还是寄到家呀嗯
Lucia: Are you sending it to your school or home?
Alice:寄到家学校没地方
Alice: Sending it home, no space at school.
Lucia: 对我也是
Lucia: Me too.
Lucia: 我是那个那个小桌子我想
Lucia: I want to send my small table.
Alice:那你是不是还得把它拆了呀对
Alice: You have to disassemble it, right?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 因为感觉就用一下就扔掉
Lucia: It feels like such a waste to use it once and throw it away.
Lucia: 有点太可惜了
Lucia: It's a bit of a shame.
Alice:是的
Alice: Yeah.
Alice:我的桌布打算让刘婷给我继承走
Alice: I'm planning to let Liu Ting inherit my tablecloth.
其他人：不是说保洁回来打扫吗
Others: Weren't we told the cleaning staff would come back to clean?
Lucia: 我们就简单的扫一下
Lucia: We'll just do a quick sweep.
Lucia: 要不然话地上纸有点太多了
Lucia: Otherwise, there are too many papers on the floor.
Lucia: 就是大家会有点不太好落脚
Lucia: It's kind of hard to walk around.
Lucia: 现在这样应该啊
Lucia: It should be fine now.
Lucia: 这还有一个袋子
Lucia: There's another bag here.
Lucia: 给他扫了吧
Lucia: Let's sweep it up.
Alice:老板呢
Alice: Where's the boss?
Alice:老板什么时候录房间
Alice: When is the boss going to record the room?
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Alice:什么没听清
Alice: What? I didn't hear clearly.
Lucia: 这个形状现在好神奇啊啊
Lucia: This shape is so amazing now.
Alice:什么呀
Alice: What?
Lucia: 就是这个水龙头管子的形状
Lucia: I mean the shape of this faucet pipe.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:哎呀吃这个好上瘾呢
Alice: Wow, this is so addictive.
Lucia: 我怎么又找不到自己的手机
Lucia: Why can't I find my phone again?
Alice:你要去哪呢
Alice: Where are you going?
Tasha: 嗯哪也不去
Tasha: Hmm, nowhere.
Alice:你要出门吗
Alice: Are you going out?
Tasha: 连连个地都没有不去
Tasha: There's no place to go anyway.
Alice:啊老板呢
Alice: Ah, where's the boss?
Tasha: 他他随便
Tasha: He's... he's just around.
Alice:他在上面那啥吗
Alice: Is he doing something upstairs?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Tasha: 没看见我也不知道
Tasha: I haven't seen him, no idea.
Alice:我以为他要开始录了
Alice: I thought he was going to start recording.
Tasha: 他是不是好几天没发工钱
Tasha: Hasn't he not paid us for several days?
Alice:发什么工钱
Alice: Paid what?
Tasha: 工钱
Tasha: Wages.
Alice:工钱工资
Alice: Wages, salary.
Alice:嗯应该是最后统一结吧
Alice: Hmm, probably pays it all at once at the end.
Alice:哎呦这样嗑瓜子好不舒服呀
Alice: Oh, it's so uncomfortable to eat sunflower seeds like this.
Alice:所以老板老板设置的那种红包
Alice: So the boss's red envelope setup...
Alice:是为是仪式感吗
Alice: Is it for the ceremony?
Tasha: 可能吧哈哈平板呢
Tasha: Maybe, haha. Where's the tablet?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:工钱
Alice: Wages.
Tasha: 嗯你朋友呢
Tasha: Hmm, where's your friend?
Alice:回去打第五人格了啊
Alice: Going back to play Identity V, huh?
Tasha: 啊他不跟你哦哦
Tasha: Ah, he's not playing with you?
Alice:搁那呢刘婷你在吗
Alice: Over there, Liu Ting, are you here?
Alice:想你啊
Alice: I miss you.
其他人：想我多看看我
Others: If you miss me, just look at me more.
其他人：哈哈
Alice:我看到你来火
Alice: Seeing you makes me angry.
Alice:打第五人格吗
Alice: Playing Identity V?
Alice:能打的动不能
Alice: Can you handle it?
Alice:我给你开热点
Alice: I'll give you a hotspot.
Tasha: 有无线网吗
Tasha: Is there Wi-Fi?
Alice:唉这无线网跟没有差不多
Alice: Eh, this Wi-Fi is basically useless.
Alice:但我热点还行
Alice: But my hotspot is okay.
Alice:求求我
Alice: Beg me.
Alice:你求我一下
Alice: Just beg me a little.
Alice:不求拉到
Alice: If you don't beg, forget it.
Alice:又掉了
Alice: It dropped again.
Alice:没掉没啊我靠
Alice: Didn't drop, did it? Oh my god.
Alice:是那个白的还是绿的呀
Alice: Is it the white or the green one?
其他人：都掉
Others: Both dropped.
Alice:呵呵
Alice: Haha.
Alice:你能帮我粘一下吗
Alice: Can you help me stick it?
Alice:你可以了对吧
Alice: You can do it, right?
Tasha: 14-7
Tasha: 14-7.
Alice:咳一会不是渴不渴了
Alice: Cough, in a bit, I'm not thirsty anymore.
Tasha: 不知道为什么这伙食这么好
Tasha: Don't know why the food is so good here.
Tasha: 可是我却食欲大减
Tasha: But I lost my appetite.
Alice:累的
Alice: Tired.
Tasha: 不知道我在学校伙食还没这好呢
Tasha: I don't know, at school, the food isn't this good.
Tasha: 天天吃的比这多
Tasha: I eat more than this every day.
Alice:我觉得这在这吃饭太油了
Alice: I think the food here is too greasy.
Alice:感觉这几天身体负担很重
Alice: Feels like my body's been burdened these days.
Tasha: 所以什么都吃不下感觉
Tasha: So, I can't eat anything.
Alice:回去我得吃几天素刷刷油
Alice: When I get back, I need to eat vegetarian for a few days to cleanse the oil.
Alice:对呀说了不磕了
Alice: Yeah, I said no more snacks.
Alice:还磨我得远离这
Alice: Yet you still nag me, I need to stay away from this.
Alice:洗洗手
Alice: Wash my hands.
Alice:一开始
Alice: At first.
Alice:不经意心就飘过去
Alice: Unintentionally, my heart just drifted away.
Alice:婷你在吗
Alice: Ting, are you here?
Alice:干嘛开门
Alice: Why are you opening the door?
Alice:付费开门
Alice: Pay to open the door.
Alice:别坐在里面不出声
Alice: Don't just sit there quietly.
Alice:我知道你在家
Alice: I know you're home.
Alice:开门
Alice: Open the door.
Alice:哼我靠
Alice: Ugh, damn it.
Alice:怎么钓的越来越多
Alice: Why are you catching more and more?
Alice:真是麻烦
Alice: This is so troublesome.
Alice:这得逼钓
Alice: This forces the catch.
其他人：哎呀实在不行你就迟早会掉的
Others: Oh no, if you can't do it, you'll eventually fall.
Alice:那不行看见一下我就得改一下
Alice: That's not going to work. I have to change it once I see it.
Alice:咋了
Alice: What's wrong?
Alice:正好别拍卖了
Alice: Good, don't auction it.
Alice:这送我不得了
Alice: Just give it to me.
其他人：拍个手链不好看
Others: Auctioning a bracelet doesn't look good.
Alice:我看哪个
Alice: Which one am I looking at?
Alice:我不要铁的
Alice: I don't want the iron one.
其他人：不好看是吧
Others: Doesn't look good, right?
Alice:我摸铁的
Alice: I touched the iron one.
Alice:我手那啥
Alice: My hand, you know.
Alice:我终于勇敢说爱你
Alice: I finally had the courage to say I love you.
Alice:你他
Alice: You...
Alice:妈的别像个小黄人你搁那嘚嘚嘚
Alice: Damn it, don't act like a minion, babbling there.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha.
Alice:我看见这个床咸咸的我
Alice: I saw this bed, it feels salty.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈我就想哭
Alice: Hahahahahaha, it makes me want to cry.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Alice:啊你给我拿个水我渴了
Alice: Ah, get me some water, I'm thirsty.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:婷你还是爱我的哈
Alice: Stop, you still love me, right?
Alice:哈哈你干啥我还没看你就扔了
Alice: Haha, what are you doing? I haven't even looked and you threw it away.
其他人：真的不好看
Others: It really doesn't look good.
Alice:你让我看看
Alice: Let me see.
其他人：你掏出来
Others: Take it out.
Alice:哈哈我看看
Alice: Haha, take it out and let me see.
其他人：开心了开心了
Others: Happy now? Happy now?
Alice:开心了
Alice: Happy now.
Alice:这铁的吗
Alice: Is this iron?
其他人：对
Others: Yes.
Alice:你也不怕过敏
Alice: Aren't you afraid of allergies?
Alice:能给我买个金的吗
Alice: Can you buy me a gold one?
其他人：金色的行吗
Others: Is a gold-colored one okay?
Alice:不太行
Alice: Not really.
Alice:哈哈我要gold
Alice: Haha, I want gold.
Alice:gold靠金咋念啊不会
Alice: How do you pronounce gold in Chinese? I don't know.
其他人：gold哈哈哎呀
Others: Gold, haha, oh man.
Alice:你要这个桌布不要
Alice: Do you want this tablecloth?
Alice:嗯这俩我买俩
Alice: Hmm, I'll buy these two.
其他人：我研究研究可能能用得上
Others: I'll study them, maybe I can use them.
Alice:这俩拿走呗
Alice: Just take these two.
其他人：我们家也有这种小桌布
Others: We also have small tablecloths like this at home.
Alice:拿走我跟你说
Alice: Take them, I'm telling you.
Alice:这就是姐爱你的证明
Alice: This is proof that I love you, sis.
Alice:你看你那小桌子这挠的铺上
Alice: Look at your little table, it’s scratched, cover it with this.
Alice:田园知道吗
Alice: Do you know pastoral style?
Alice:森系
Alice: Forest style.
Alice:你这个人都增添一丝淑女的气质
Alice: This will add a touch of elegance to you.
Alice:我服了
Alice: I give up.
其他人：拍个照吧
Others: Let's take a picture.
其他人：哎你不是晚上还要吃完晚饭走吗
Others: Hey, aren't you leaving after dinner?
Alice:吃呗估计是你也在
Alice: Yeah, probably with you too.
Alice:你想走你也可以跟我提前走
Alice: If you want to leave early, you can go with me.
Alice:但是留着吃着不就不行吗
Alice: But if we stay to eat, then we can't leave.
Alice:吃完再走
Alice: Leave after dinner.
其他人：我早点回去
Others: I'll go back earlier.
Alice:我带电脑了
Alice: I brought my laptop.
Alice:哦对你没弄我搁这
Alice: Oh right, you didn't get it, I'll put it here.
其他人：我有
Others: I have one.
Alice:那你要不用我电脑
其他人：也行
Others: That's fine too.
Alice:你要用你要
Alice: Do you need to use it?
Alice:你要咋传啊
Alice: How are you going to upload it?
其他人：就是登系统然后把它上传
Others: Just log into the system and upload it.
Alice:但你的论文呢
其他人：手机里
Others: On my phone.
其他人：我连知网查重的文件都存在手机里
Others: I even saved the files for the plagiarism check on my phone.
Alice:那你可以直接用我的电脑传啊
Alice: Then you can just use my laptop to upload it.
Alice:等会录完吧
Alice: Let's do it after recording.
Alice:我那电脑在箱子里不想打开了
Alice: My laptop is in the suitcase, I don't want to open it now.
Alice:录完之后下午就没啥事了卫生也
Alice: After recording, we won't have much to do in the afternoon, and the cleaning too.
Alice:也冲了也也打扫的差不多了
Alice: I've flushed it, and it's almost clean.
Alice:你那撸屁真的像个手榴弹
Alice: Your fart really sounds like a grenade.
Alice:我跟你说
Alice: I'm telling you.
Alice:粉色内胆海胆
Alice: Pink sea urchin inner lining.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:画完了你看我能扔进去不能
Alice: It's finished. Let's see if I can throw it in.
Alice:我觉得不能
Alice: I don't think I can.
Alice:of course确实不能哈哈哈
Alice: Of course, I definitely can't. Hahaha.
Alice:丢脸哈哈哈
Alice: So embarrassing. Hahaha.
其他人：先给你一个行吧
Others: Let's give you a pass first.
Alice:好这次我估计还是不行
Alice: Okay, but I think I still can't do it this time.
Alice:哈哈哈哈再来
Alice: Hahahaha, let's try again.
Alice:一次我靠
Alice: One more time, damn it.
Alice:不信了
Alice: I don't believe it.
其他人：等会
Others: Wait a minute.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice:玩吧
Alice: Let's play.
Alice:哎呀有什么东西
Alice: Oh no, what's this thing?
其他人：注意啊这个手机内容不要拍
Others: Be careful, don't record the content on this phone.
Alice:无所谓俺家地址都要泄露了
Alice: Doesn't matter, my home address is about to be leaked anyway.
Alice:三天三夜
Alice: Three days and three nights.
其他人：谁把灯拿开了
Alice:狗
Alice: Damn it.
其他人：你啊
Others: It was you.
Alice:你
Alice: You.
其他人：没碰啊
Others: I didn't touch it.
其他人：哪来的灯啊
Others: Where's the light coming from?
Alice:你说哪个灯啊
Alice: Which light are you talking about?
Alice:不会是这个吧
Alice: Could it be this one?
Alice:对啊坏了买的灯机
Alice: Yeah, it's broken, the one we bought.
Alice:我以为你说那个灯
Alice: I thought you meant that light.
Alice:那个灯我确实没开
Alice: I really didn't turn on that light.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahahaha.
其他人：哈哈哈神经病
Others: Hahaha, you're crazy.
Alice:这网差的要死
Alice: This internet is so bad.
其他人：我我去闲鱼上
Others: I'm going to check on Xianyu.
Alice:我操哈哈哈下次一定
Alice: Damn it, hahaha, next time for sure.
Alice:这网也太卡了
Alice: The internet is too laggy.
Alice:像屏蔽一一样
Alice: It's like being blocked.
Alice:不是他咋越掉越多呢
Alice: Why is he losing more and more?
其他人：哎呀累 3号 我3号
Others: Oh, I'm tired. Number 3, I'm number 3.
Alice:我靠
Alice: Damn it.
Alice:你有的啥
Alice: What do you have?
Alice:我没有
Alice: I don't have it.
其他人：你把手拿远点
Others: Move your hand away a bit.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:咱俩一个生理构造的好吗
Alice: We have the same anatomy, okay?
Alice:我们好像有点暧昧了
Alice: We seem to be a bit ambiguous.
Alice:我们才认识一个多月
Alice: We've only known each other for a little over a month.
其他人：那你觉得发展太快了吗
Others: Do you think it's developing too fast?
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Alice:救命啊哈哈
Alice: Help, haha.
Alice:救命啊
Alice: Help.
Alice:把我那个手机拿过来
Alice: Bring me my phone.
Alice:救命啊
Alice: Help.
Alice:救救我
Alice: Save me.
Alice:救救救救
Alice: Save save save.
Alice:还姨姨呢
Alice: Still calling me auntie.
Alice:一开始
Alice: At first.
Alice:你天天给我发那讨厌的什么抖音
Alice: You kept sending me those annoying TikToks every day.
其他人：没看没看
Others: Didn't watch, didn't watch.
其他人：没给你发
Others: Didn't send to you.
其他人：给狗发的
Others: Sent them to the dog.
Alice:啧我操
Alice: Tsk, damn it.
Alice:我真是受不了了
Alice: I really can't stand it.
其他人：哈哈啊呀
Others: Hahaha, oh my.
Alice:烦死了滚啊去死啊
Alice: So annoying, get lost, go die.
Alice:哎这个布你你有用吗
Alice: Hey, do you need this cloth?
Alice:你万一野餐的时候还能往地上一扑
Alice: You can spread it out when you go for a picnic.
Alice:这还能洗的干啥的
Alice: You can wash it or whatever.
Alice:或者你直接扑你地上坐上
Alice: Or just spread it out and sit on it.
Alice:可以
Alice: Okay.
Alice:反正留着也是便宜别人
Alice: Anyway, keeping it will just benefit others.
其他人：3号3号3号
Others: Number 3, number 3, number 3.
Alice:你要去跟哪个狗男人约会了
Alice: Which dog man are you going to date?
其他人：是之前
Others: It was before.
其他人：本来是2号
Others: It was supposed to be number 2.
其他人：结果我之前提前手快买张3号的票
Others: But I quickly bought a ticket for number 3 earlier.
其他人：我闲鱼上把它转出去
Others: I'll sell it on Xianyu.
Alice:你真是个人才
Alice: You are really talented.
Alice:我开热点了
Alice: I've turned on the hotspot.
其他人：不稀罕
Others: Not interested.
Alice:不稀罕拉倒
Alice: Fine, suit yourself.
Alice:别玩
Alice: Stop playing.
Alice:玩一下保卫萝卜
Alice: Let's play "Guard Carrot."
Alice:给AI一点震撼
Alice: Give the AI a shock.
其他人：哎呦哈哈哈哈对啊
Others: Oh, hahaha, yeah.
Alice:对啊
Alice: Yeah.
Alice:嗯哎呦烦死了
Alice: Ugh, so annoying.
Alice:谁懂啊
Alice: Who understands this?
Alice:去你妈的
Alice: Damn it.
Alice:我操说脏话了
Alice: Oh crap, I swore.
Alice:B
Alice: B.